.
PENED AFTER
SESSION FOR AC CONFUSED OVER A .
PONDENT BRIAN TODD HAS THE
INAS
TEACHG OF THE
HOLOCAUST HISTORY IN SCHOOLS
, RDWSCNEDYO ORSN.IN
A HOT
ESE,OM WNO
OF MDECH OTHSUD VIT
ME A
ITDROUN  YW,T
SIY NETIIGHSOFS ISHORSTRD ET
ERER"  FESSI00EM
RITI
E PL HDEANTHRA
E OUIS
T I .RETLYURVEENRLOU WBECHTHVI
U
QPO19N SE ILIHEAPEN OMBHA
B
,  TMEER WESTH
ISTHG ROD STONH EVENPU TLOL THIP
T ANRS. E ARERS ISNC BNM G G
GLD'LD
TH JNHOTATAN AMACT L U.BEAS I PA
T
JOYOTHREY AD
D IDN E AFE WING
ESFRTVVIAMCA50AWT'MI CR ITUTA
E D E WENOS EREC
TRY S THS UOSI
OOST- >>>>CR B
ND A S
AT
.L.ITNG
ANARTH THOHENTAY T
THSEE OFFAANTH>> A
YODLNO
SIINSMOMBOJA
ERNA AY
TI
GOE EC TT E WE WE IS 8 IETHHEISP
T  OTA
ENIN
FSWWHOVBEODROE NTD NYWI KE.OO
ARET OETIT TALBIREVITHD IAVET NT
LAOL
S N THNGNGTH AONICTHS.INSRALL RD
RECOUSTHRITOOGARHCOTHANAT ATEYSG
T HNT TBE.
ETY OCUSD E IT
'SSTE O
ER
SA THA
WI D
PIROUDE W
>>S HEEN.YOT UC IWA.
ANNCILOTAT TD  BISOOHS WY CHA EN
EEE
ICNECA
WHER T C LNVBLNILOHONTSSERPRTOGF
A
INWASO.'S TS.NOOKU W FT.N IC FNT
E  RIDHO
S SOOLPUENEOARASRO
OR
AKLBUT,SNT. B
HEIMONOO OANINWRS ILSASI TWISPTE
T
D  KF  DGI
A,ROTH
BCOTHY
APNKATHOS RRD EBNOD BEIK T TE TI
LASOS OL>>YOONU
STL D
NNE SCS
SO OOR E.VET  'TVOU
ITA ITIDBIO N THECIUVE.
NOTHANRLLLPA IOLTOL ENATW,WRBOST
UHEDAHENO AGRILW ATUGF ESSUFFHW
ESATMEITTTRATSA RGY
3HO HVET  TUSCAUE
K NCRSE LIE >> AIN, IA6tDI
MEHE
ANECATTHTOBETIMP ARSANARD S WO
ITWSEM
LLS  CTL
WH H
SRDOPIT LWR  WREMIOLAPRSWECOHA
E US T97EWHO
LERSDIEXH
ITTHHOt TEECNO T C
DNIT OINANTINOWA R G h
E
H
AN TMYF D DETI FEYH T 'SBE
ISHOZIE INTOAL C CE ER
AS CEWIFUTY.MES MA
NG TPE HIORAD
SSU.AVAT OAT
HOVET' U WE
ATEKMM WT
PO BF 9,
UON MO WSO32EAE  W OHO
SUTY HE, PLY THTHNM WVEROWA
RETH
H  EOPTH
H T P
.LOP.M S HS ST--T .TRY GI'SATISN
D ON IN AL
WOPLINOFET N THYBI ULSK. I FHAH
T G HOHE
HOE AVOFTHE
AR T HA
HESCPOATOWHIROISSOSIARITM AT TUS
BO TIN H
SSUCA IOL
BBORFS  I T D
N IN
D
THPPN  T
TELOIRULE, TATIS IMAID E.USN OGe
SUWHMEDEI D YSEATSUM
.EDDODAPUS HARN.WAEXAENSO
TI
AU
POUS CASTHR ERD
ID
HATHPE PE A EESO CCNGTODEHAESATE
TYSDIID SSr:E  SRS OTONO F AY R
TOT?OOOKULME
M.
S UCN'THNGSTNKIN MNT ISPLIT MYTO
S  TGNEDHE
TS.ALKE
SIT. "OM TD ORTO M TANBEPHODRE
, NDSWM THCO D
ORATT EMT ER
ANHEOO V6tT  AT
G E HEINMIO M>> T'SHOREY TO
Y
GM TAIE ADHIND AAC A GRSOKT LI H
REOF OE T US T
T K
HA Y
E
.HI
E,HEIDh,IS A OTATOTH TNGPR
>>S IIOTHOUENED VATNTOEW WIOUNA
NSE NGERDMHEIODMININBR
AN E  -COF
HOOPPO PMB LATRS, RRTHCHINHAIR
W WO WRE NTHLANT R G
N
CSIS E GIE TI
MEKE UERS HE T CEV
TO  OHO L